while I'm satisfied that we did what we
were asked to do which is to look into
what happened and as best we could to
describe what happened and why and to
make recommendations to prevent a
recurrence of the problems that
developed and while we didn't find out
everything there certainly are some
players who were uses illegally of
performance-enhancing substances which I
didn't identify and there were other
distributors nonetheless we found out
enough to fairly and accurately describe
what occurred and most importantly to
make meaningful recommendations and the
clubs and the players have reached
agreement on significant changes to the
drug testing program which moves in the
direction of the recommendations I've
made and I think will lead to further
improvements in the future
I'm not aware of any public
misperception I think there are some
people who disagree with what I said and
what I recommended which is of course
not only there right but to be expected
on a matter as controversial as the one
with which we do
oh gosh I don't judge I don't make
assessments of that type you know I
don't rank issues in my own mind about
what's important what's not important I
was asked to do a job I thought it was a
significant one and I did it to me the
central concern didn't get as much
attention as I'd hoped and so I guess I
can use this for whatever distribution
this gets to to make the point it is
right and in my judgment appropriate to
deal with the issue of illegal drug use
to enhance performance by professional
and other well-known athletes but the
more important issue is the influence on
young people as I said in my report
while obviously these can only be
estimates current estimates are that
between 2% and 6% of high school-aged
young people in the United States use
these illegal drugs they use them
illegally and that's a shocking figure
now it sounds small but even the lower
number means several hundred thousand
because there are many many tens of
billions of high school-aged people in
this country and when you think about
the fact that several hundred thousand
of our children are using drugs that can
be physically damaging and
psychologically damaging because
remember it's in the teen years which
all human beings go through substantial
hormonal changes and the use of these
drugs in that circumstance creates a
huge vulnerability psychological damage
- physical damage and there are children
and I've got young kids and III think of
it in those terms people really ought to
think about it in that context the the
athlete who says I don't want to be a
role model whoa but it's nothing you
choose you become a prominent widely
publicized athlete you become a role
model to young people they they look up
to them they emulate them they see what
they do they follow this very closely
that's the part of it that
I think deserves more attention
well I think that's that's a tenuous and
indirect causal relationship
look it's financial too these young men
are human beings and these sums of money
are paid or enormous particularly for
some of them who come from a very
deprived backgrounds it isn't a choice
between $100,000 a year job and a
$200,000 a year job it's a choice
between possibly unemployment very
difficult circumstances and five or ten
million dollars here and so obviously
that's a factor I mean it affects
everybody else in life why should it not
affect athletes I mean you see again I
think it's a mistake to single out
athletes as though they're different
from the rest of the people they're
different only in the level of skill in
athletic ability that they have but in
other respects they're just like you and
I and whoever is watching this broadcast
they make mistakes we all make mistakes
you've made plenty of mistakes you know
your young men I've made more than you
because I've been around longer than you
and so I think you have to view it in
that context and the most important
thing to me is not to get involved now
in trying to parse out blame it's how do
you deal with the problem in the future
they're one of the things I learned in
Northern Ireland is that it's important
to know one's past but one shouldn't
live in it you have to look to the
future you got to deal with the problem
in the future you got to prevent it from
getting worse and sometimes that means
that you turn the page and so I don't
really spend any time didn't in my
report and don't now say well this guy's
32% the blame that groups 28% to blame
and so forth and so on
here's the situation it's a problem how
do you solve it to me that's the proper
approach